welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of Disney's
2023 The Haunted Mansion along with the
2003 film adaptation starring Eddie
Murphy in the 2021 Halloween special
Muppets Haunted Mansion and having a
famed series of short stories and being
one of the most popular attractions
you'd think Disney would stop there but
no they did not our newest sounded
Mansion is directed by director of dear
white people Justin Simeon who's also a
former Disneyland employee and written
by Katie dippled and it follows the
Paranormal tour guide as he helps a
single mom and her son with their
Newfound Haunted Mansion between the
minor jump scares heart-frenching and
Grim storyline this movie was just
pulled off so many laughs and is a clear
adaptation of the ride of Disneyland
like this movie is pretty much the
experience of riding the ride at
Disneyland and I loved all the Easter
eggs in it so if you're a fan of the
Disney attraction you're gonna love this
movie if you like confused Danny DeVito
you'll love this movie an array of
surprise cameos a ton of Easter eggs and
just a lot of advice on Grief and
learning how to continue fourth as the
shell of the person you once were after
losing a loved one a lot to talk about
let's get into it and this video is
sponsored by Squarespace the all-in one
platform that makes launching your own
website a breeze like the first movie in
like the Disneyland attraction we opened
the movie in beautiful New Orleans Jamie
Lee Curtis says Madame Leota says
welcome foolish Mortals which is what
the ghost host of the Disney ride says
this narration at the beginning of the
movie explains the beauty in the
afterlife but also the ghost host is
narrating his own death on the
attraction I actually asked Jamie Lee
Curtis about the metaphysics of Madame
Leota in the crystal ball I'm just
curious about the metaphysics of it do
you think she is trapped inside the
crystal ball or is she in another realm
and just as like FaceTiming them she is
fully trapped in there there she has air
purifiers and you know Febreze yeah I
was able to interview Jamie Lee Curtis
Tiffany haddish Rosario Dawson locate
Stanfield and director Justin Simeon the
full interviews are on the break room
Channel and I'm gonna include some
excerpts throughout this breakdown but
please know that we did those back in
June before the SAG after strike and sag
is okayed cast of media Outlets
fulfilling prior agreements like this so
we're good we're good okay it's now new
two years and we meet lakeith
stanfield's character Ben an
astrophysicist and later revealed wife
Alyssa who gives ghost tours Ben says he
doesn't drink much so they share a beer
setting up his transition to heavy
drinking later on they bond over their
careers not being similar at all and the
sweet happy moment is broken up by a
Time jump to the current day where a
bartender played by Joe Coy confronts
Ben about still conducting Alyssa's
ghost tours now that she is dead bummer
I love lucky Stanfield in this movie how
he brings his jumpiness and his
skepticism and all these Shady
situations so I asked him about his
background from acting in Jordan peels
get out and other horror movies that he
grew up with kind of grew up watching
some of the horror films that weren't
technically horror films but were
horrific kind of like like boys in the
hood you know it had some scenes in
there that were really hard and
Manchester Society stuff like that I
grew up watching a lot of hard violence
that was mirroring real violence in the
world and and around me and the
environment I grew up in I saw a lot of
that and experienced a lot of that so
those were kind of the hard things to to
contend with but it also felt nice to
know that the world that I was
experiencing and seeing around me other
people had also experienced and been
through so I felt like I wasn't as alone
sometimes and where I was living and
coming from we passed various New
Orleans landmarks like Jackson Square
lafitte's blacksmith Tavern one of the
oldest bars in North America and we
spent a lot of time on Royal Street
where Ben lives and we see Lafayette
Cemetery but in this movie they call it
fernet Cemetery as the Jazz man plays a
U-Haul truck drives by and it's
featuring a man with a skull the normal
New Orleans U-Hauls feature the classic
Mardi Gras mask in jester also get a
shot of the truck driving on the
causeway this is the long long bridge
that connects Mandeville to Metairie we
got the same closing shot in the first
Haunted Mansion movie when the family
drives away then we see the Haunted
Mansion the movie version clearly looks
bigger than the attraction but the same
pillars the design of the guard rails
the colors the windows it's all
identical once Gabby Rosario Dawson and
her son Travis played by Chase W Dylan
enter the house I mean come on it is the
ride the same long quarter the carpeting
I love it Justin Simeon actually talked
about how important the mansion's
architecture was to him there's so much
going on in the movie that there's
plenty for you if you watch it again
I'll say that uh particularly when it
comes to the architectural details of
the house and you know if you if you
know my work or if you know what I'm a
big I'm a fan of reference
um and we all those movies that you
mentioned uh I I watched a lot and and
made the team watch especially uh 1963's
The Haunting
um you know that was kind of like the OG
haunted House movie that it feels to me
that when they the imagineers went in to
make the Haunted Mansion that movie had
to have been in their heads there's a
lot of corollaries visually between
um just how that movie sort of Slants
mirrors and makes you sort of look at
spaces just beyond where you are and
just kind of the angling and and you
sort of feel like the house becomes more
and more demented the longer they're in
there there's a lot of that that's just
in the vibe of the Haunted Mansion
um and and and so hopefully by osmosis
finds his way back in the Haunted
Mansion movie when Travis opens the door
we see a ghoulish lionhead dead center
and a snake-like handle which is at the
Haunted Mansion traction at Disneyland
once Travis gets into his room of only
cobwebs he's greeted by Constance
Constance hatch away is a ghost who
stays in the Attic with her Hatchet
she's decapitated her five husbands and
waits for more sutus to kill then the
night statue starts moving we saw this
play out in the 2003 movie when Jim
Evers was trying to save his kids we
also get this on the the Disneyland ride
it just suddenly moves its Shield we
learn once you enter the house you can
try to leave but the spirits will follow
you until you return so anyone can
really be a hitchhiking ghost in the
logic of this movie it takes about two
hours until you're scared or irritated
to come back to the house as they drive
away we see the hatbox ghost eerily
saying you'll be back back oh Jared Leto
you don't have to work that hard to be
creepy the hack box ghost is yet another
iconic ghost from the Disney attraction
that box ghost is actually part of the
original lineup when the Haunted Mansion
did previews in August of 1969 but the
effect of the head going inside the Hat
Box just didn't work properly so he's
decommissioned wow but he began to
reappear in 2009 in art and souvenirs
for the 40th anniversary and in 2010
when Guillermo del Toro was attached to
the project he wanted to make the movie
around the character which led to the
hatbox ghost return in popularity and
returned to the Disneyland attraction in
2015. so we are back with Ben who's
visited by fake priest Kent played by
Owen Wilson wow he arrives with a
beautiful cat that belongs to nobody
Kent begsman to join and help rid
Gabby's Mansion of ghosts this is when
we learned that Ben started to study
spectrophotography making it possible
for him to take pictures of ghosts to do
this he uses a Quantum lens and the idea
of a Quantum lens is 100 real the
quantum camera takes images of the
Unseen a normal camera captures a light
and it bounces back from an object but
here you'd capture the image but the
light never bounced back though it's not
scientifically said to be a ghost they
do call it ghost Imaging after comparing
Ben to Frankenstein he offers them two
thousand dollars for the job and
immediately takes it grabs his Pentax
camera with squantum lens and heads to
the Haunted Mansion now the room that
doesn't seem to be touched on by the
ghost where Travis and Gabby feel safest
is the elevator room from the Haunted
Mansion attraction the one that you
first enter into it has the same exact
wallpaper and these same paintings that
stretch out to reveal the extra context
and we get a great reveal of that later
in the movie Gabby mentioned she found
this place on Zillow The Haunted Mansion
in New Orleans is currently listed on
Zillow and dropped to mid-july it could
be for promotional purposes but it
actually does exist on Zillow I asked
for Zaria Dawson what it meant to play a
character moving from New York to the
outskirts of Louisiana for me housing is
everything
um and I think this having shelter
having safety
um is Paramount so that was that's
something that growing up the way that I
did is very much instilled in me so I
think there was a nesting kind of thing
that I liked I liked that we all were
supposed to be in this room and how she
was caretaking for everyone and and just
under standing like even with the
circumstances wanting to make the best
of it all the time and I definitely grew
up in that sort of ethos you know I grew
up with very tenacious people who saw
issues and then problem solved how to
deal with it with Sweat Equity like just
bringing their best and if they were
challenged and they didn't know how to
do something they learned they asked
questions they weren't afraid to to
to evolve and and I really like that for
these characters unfortunately I ran out
of time before I could ask her about
Ahsoka next time Rosario to get Travis
company he has an array of action
figures sitting in that tent he kind of
reminds me of Cole and the sixth sense
but the most notable action figure of
course is Black Panther later when Kent
is creating a Dream Team he uses Neymar
to represent Bruce and storm to
represent Harriet I swear the red kid
figurine is Doctor Strange and I really
wanted to be because we eventually get
to the astral projection I mean come on
how could we not bring in the sorcerer
we also see Travis playing Marvel
Monopoly alone and this movie is sad but
that might be the saddest thing I've
ever seen like you can't play Monopoly
alone you silly silly lonely child
there's a ton of portraits on the wall
and Ben gets stuck on this one of the
Mariner now the Mariner is yet another
Easter egg the portrait lives at Tokyo
Disneyland and at Walt Disney World the
Mariner is the ghost of a sea captain
who drowned at Sea and of course we get
a glimpse of the white busts whose eyes
follow you obviously another part of the
attraction at the Disney park we are
introduced to the Duelists which in the
movie are brothers that shot each other
but appear in the Haunted Mansion at
Disneyland and in Tokyo and in Walt
Disney World we see the grandfather
clock that has 13 instead of 12 and when
it strikes 13 at midnight the Craig easy
paranormal stuff cranks up and my
grandfather clock isn't Easter egg from
the attraction as well in Tales of the
Haunted Mansion Volume 2 midnight and
metamliotas a man by the name of William
Gaines wants to speak to his departed
sister the random librarian offers him a
chance to speak with Madame Leota back
at the Mysterious Mansion as the man
tells him a bunch of short stories
William grows impatient eventually
leaving and exploring the Mansion for
Leota he wanders into a maze of endless
staircases and encounter its constants
only at midnight as he finally meet
Leota not only does that sound like a
lot this story but Ben ends up at the
endless staircase another Easter egg to
the attraction at Magic Kingdom he also
has a horrible encounter with Constance
so Justin and Katie are playing with the
books as well then Ben leaves with only
doubts and to his surprise has guarded
his own hitchhiking ghost it's the
Mariner and I love the Mariner only
wants to watch Deadliest Catch it's
pretty sweet I actually asked Justin
Simeon why he and Katie dippold chose
the Mariner as the ghost that follows
Ben home that's just always been one of
the ghosts that I'm weirdly fascinated
by like from the painting alone there's
just something about the Ancient Mariner
painting that always is like caught my
eye I'm always like I'm always carrying
like navel symbols I don't I don't know
why there's something about the sea and
then like in my research for this movie
um I read something about like how water
and the Sea and you know Ocean Travel is
often like a metaphor for emotion and
tough feelings and I I can't say I did
all of that on purpose but I thought
like that's a really great choice
because this is a character that has a
lot you know been has a lot of strong
tough emotions that he's trying to move
through and you've got this Mariner who
is like clearly in danger girl like
looking at the painting and yet there's
a there's a knowing Stern calmness about
him that tells you like oh he's been
through worse and I don't know I felt
like that all played really well
together when Ben goes back to the
mansion all the creepy stuff starts
happening again with a floating
candelabra we all know that from the
Disneyland ride as Ben Waters down the
creepy quarter with a ton of paintings
the one that stands out is the man with
an ax and a pig this may be one of his
Mr 11. I think this is an homage to the
ghost hosts in the ride that kills
himself in the stretching room they both
have the same features white hair white
eyes and an ax having a website is like
having a business card if you run a
business you kind of need one and that
means you need Squarespace Squarespace
is an all-in-one platform that provides
you with everything you need to do
whatever you need with your website
Squarespace says templates and designs
for every category and use case so even
if you're making your very first website
using Squarespace makes it super easy to
customize your look update your content
and add features to fit your unique
needs if you're selling merch
Squarespace makes it easy to do that too
you can design your products then save
time and money by letting Squarespace
handle production inventory and shipping
and if you're selling any other kind of
physical Goods digital Goods or even a
service Squarespace makes it easy to
build your storefront and grow your
business to check out for yourself head
to squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com new rockstars to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain we start to learn the lore
behind the house and it has a lot to do
with William Gracie who is a tombstone
at the Haunted Mansion ride William
Gracie was in tribute to Disney's
imagineer Yale Gracie who had a hand in
making the Haunted Mansion attraction we
learned that the Mansion was fully built
out of nowhere then William Gracie
bought it off an undisclosed buyer and
that his wife Eleanor died from yellow
fever we later learned from Adam Leota
that he hired Leota to help him reach
Eleanor and she performed Seance after
Seance until they let the wrong ghost in
and lured William to his death by poison
in the 2003 adaptation the owner of the
manor was Edward Gracie and he lost his
wife to poison it doesn't feel
completely the same but the same homage
to Gracie and arsenic are always finding
a way into the franchise the ghost that
lured William is later revealed to be
the Hat Box ghost and he needs one
thousand Souls he's currently at 9.99
the ghost hosted The Haunted Mansion
attractions will sometimes refer to the
ghosts as the happy hunt we have 999
happy haunts here but there's room for a
thousand yeah flip that 99 you get 666
and holy matista we're going to hell
regardless the motive to get to to 1000
was always a tale linked to the haunted
mansion's ghost host when Harriet
decides to leave until they pay her up
front she returns two hours later saying
a ghost's horse was chasing her through
her bedroom which Tiffany haddish makes
a reference to later in my interview
with her in the 2003 Honda Mansion we
saw the ghost horse carriage in action I
believe this one is just a horse just
another Easter egg to the Haunted
Mansion attraction they find out there
is a seance room and they get to the
entrance behind a painting of a lovely
woman and I'm pretty sure this is April
to December a painting at the Haunted
Mansion that from one angle is a lovely
young woman and then by December she's a
lowly mean old hag when they arrive at
the Seance room each chair is different
the Wicker leather chair for Harriet
resembles a dune buggy the chair Ben
gets has the same pattern as the chair
on the attraction ride we see near the
night statue Kent has a rustic chair
with heart-like designs Travis has the
tiny wooden boy chair and Gabby has a
black and red velvet chair with a raven
and this raven you can see on the chair
with Madame Leota in the Haunted Mansion
Seance room but it's also seen
throughout the entire ride which is why
it's so funny when Bruce says am I the
only one that didn't know that bird was
alive when it flew away when Harriet
begins trying to reach Madame Leota
she's immediately scrambled in her chair
not only does it resemble the dune
buggies of the ride and Justice Simeon
indicated that was the intention here it
moves like one two immediately spins her
around and shoves her down the hallway
out the door mimicking the ride so
Harriet explains how the souls are
trapped here essentially the soul stuck
here were not at peace and souls that
moved on that she cannot reach must have
been at peace this calms Ben who is
still grieving over losing his wife
Alyssa in the car accident and this is
when Harriet mentions ghost Wings ghost
wings are when a loved one passes on but
leaves little hints that they are still
with you like the tater tots I am
obsessed with the idea of ghost swings
and both Tiffany haddish and Justin
Simeon opened up about their personal
ghost Wings when my grandma passed away
last year one of my friends a few days
have to say oh you know your grandmother
she will like send a white feather every
time you see a white feather that's your
grandmother letting you know that she's
around every time you see one right and
then like the next day or day after I'm
coming out my bedroom and there are
feathers all over the living room
everywhere and there's a dead bird right
there and my cat's like hey Mom my aunt
Virgie passed uh just before
um I made my my second movie and I'll
never forget the day after her funeral
sitting and staring at a clock and the
the sort of minute hand was stuck on the
V and it wouldn't move past the V and I
and I felt her presence first I just
felt her and I saw it I stared at this
clock and it was just stuck on the V on
the five and I I even videoed it and I
caught the moment it just kept going but
it was so strange the clock was not
running out of battery it was not it
never did that again
um but yeah there's plenty of those so
Harriet when trying to perform an astral
projection spelled it only works on Ben
who grieving so much was able to leave
his own body one of many Horror homages
in this movie that just kind of reminded
me of Insidious wandering in its ghost
form when he comes across a ghost man
with his dog which I think is a shout
out to the caretaker from the ride but
the caretaker wasn't dead so did he and
his dog die we made the hitchhiking
ghost the classic ones from the ride
they'd look exactly the same from the
2003 film Ezra Bean is the tallest one
Professor Phineas plump is a chunky one
and good us was the one who was a
prisoner one of the ghosts terrified of
crump is a painting of the werecat Lady
this is one of the changing portraits
you see in the entrance of the Haunted
Mansion he comes across an organ player
the man with a top hat also from The
Ride Like the part of the ride where
we're looking down to see everyone in
2016 he was named air Victor Geist like
in the attraction he plays the organ and
the spirits shoot out of it once Ben is
confronted by the hatbox ghost they
realize that they need to banish him but
to banish him they need something
personal of his unfortunately we don't
know who he is so Bruce gets the idea to
get a play sketch artist comedian Hassan
Minaj and he draws him perfectly and he
had skin to make it easier to see in the
library Bruce finds out that hatbox
ghost is none other than Alistair Crump
who has the same last name As a
caretaker and I'll be so mad if Alistair
killed him in the dog the room they're
in is the library that exists in the
Haunted Mansion at Disney World and
Tokyo Disneyland Alistair was basically
her serial killer and killed a lot of
people that disowned him looked down on
him and treated him poorly and one day
his staff at his manner turned on him
and cut his head off once they find out
his name all Hell Breaks Loose and the
hatbox ghost is actively trying to
sabotage them this is my favorite Easter
egg we get to see the stretching room in
action and guess what the chamber has no
windows and no doors the wallpaper
starts to shift down and the paintings
on the wall start to help them with
words of encouragement and advice the
floor turns into sand dynamite and
alligators on the Disney ride you can
enter the room and you're welcomed by
the ghost hosts and you see four
paintings a bearded man a young woman an
old woman and a man in a bowler hat and
has room stretches it reveals the truth
behind those paintings the bearded man
sit on top lit Dynamite the young woman
bouncing on a tightrope above hungry
alligators the old man holding a rose
sitting on top of her husband's
gravestone and a hatchet embedded in his
head and the polar hat man sitting on
the shoulders of two other men who are
waist deep in quicksand not only do we
get the reveals but we get the real-time
scenario like an alligator chasing after
Travis the fear of dynamite exploding
soon the quicksand bin immediately falls
in the woman says you can go like my
husband they're surrounded by only death
luckily the Gargoyles that hang from the
walls are easy to grab and get Travis
and Ben to safety while Travis and Ben
are stuck stuck in the stretching room
Harriet and Gabby are calming Bruce down
who's having a mild heart attack Harriet
starts waving sage in front of the door
and the door starts breathing at the
Haunted Mansion ride once you're carried
backwards in the dune buggy you see a
series of doors like this one is the
breathing door in the Haunted Mansion
Bright's the fancy the door is possessed
by a shy ghost but in this movie it's
controlled by the lunatic hat box ghost
luckily Travis Ben and Kent are out of
the house and begin traveling up north
to grab something personal the hatbox
goes to banish him and on the way out
they're attacked by screaming trees and
this is a shout out to the scary trees
there are seven trees in the Honda
Mansion at Disneyland they just have
mean scary faces once they get to crump
Manor it's a dorky murder mystery type
ghost tour and it's being organized by
Winona Ryder of Beetlejuice Fame her
partner in the murder mystery is Dan
Levy as Vic and these cameos were so
weird but very entertaining I don't
understand why Dan Levy wasn't so many
trailers for this movie but from these
two we learned Alastair would place
pillows in his seat to feel above
everyone else which we actually saw one
of the ghosts doing right before his
arrival he also had a painting of his
mistress put up when he was was married
and then left his wife or his mistress
the plaque below her portrait said I do
not trust any man who reads nor woman
who reads because why would it say
anything else I guess Ben Travis and
Kent find the head of Alistair Crump
under the house and they take his hat
back to Haunted Mansion this scene where
Travis has to retrieve the Hat reminds
me of the first movie where Jim sends
his daughter into the water to retrieve
the key additionally the parts of the
krumps manner that's off limits are
blocked with a small golden chain held
by bat wings that is the same one you
see in the Haunted Mansion guiding you
to the dune buggies Travis also refers
to this under house graveyard as the
tunnel of Terror which could be a
playoff the infamous Tower of Terror
attraction once they return back to the
Haunted Mansion Kent reveals he's a
fraud just a fake priest that had
Halloween supplies but that doesn't stop
Ben from encouraging him to continue
helping the team inside Harry and Gabby
are missing in a possessed Bruce tries
to poison Kent and Ben with arsenic I
said it once and I'll say it again they
love poisoning people in these movies
where do you even get arsenic eventually
Ben Kent and Gabby and Bruce have to
take on Crump with his ghost Army he has
the bride and her five headless husbands
an executioner a headless Knight
Venetian ghost an African warrior and a
mummy and an array of diverse dead
people to get away from the ghosts as a
distraction can't Scooby-Doo runs
through different doors it's very
cartoony luckily in a heartfelt speech
Kent gets an Army of Ghosts on his side
Ben distracts the hatbox ghost Bruce
runs in with a piece of the Hat left to
finish the banishing spell and Harriet
assists Madame Liotta out of her crystal
ball as they all arrive in the backyard
Cemetery to face Crump once and for all
the ghosts are flying all over the place
and it's exactly like the ride towards
the end where you're riding through the
graveyard and the sky is filled with
ghosts I actually asked Jamie Lee Curtis
and Tiffany haddish about these two
mediums from different eras in their
connection and I just love their
response I want to share with you you
know the medium of the present is
inspired by the medium of the past and
looks up to the medium of the past and
this I feel like it's very much how we
really are like I have admired you and
looked up to you and now that I get to
like you're she's more than what I ever
expected like so much better than what I
ever like my imagination is garbage
compared to who you are in real life and
it's so I like I get teary and emotional
because I just feel like I'm so blessed
so lucky to be able to be with you like
I just
but that's what the movie is I know
right when you meet your heroes in there
just as good as you imagine you know
yeah the movies about that the movie is
about connecting to something and and
stepping up with that confidence that
person has given you to say I can do
this too which is what that I like the
sort of mentor mentee part of it even
though I really bad breath in the movie
because I didn't brush my teeth in 300
years well you're in a crystal ball
there's a bear yes but now I'm out and
then this poor woman had to be next to
me any word about it so once they are
able to banish the hatbox ghosts the
ghosts realize they don't really want to
leave and Travis and Gabby agree to keep
them company for as long as they live
the ballroom is alive with dancing
ghosts just like we see in the Disney
attraction and they dance to a newer
version of grim grinning ghosts made for
the soundtrack I assume at the end it's
Halloween and Kent is dressed as a
member of Run DMC which is hilarious
because we know Joe Simmons member of
Run DMC became rev run after his music
career practicing his Minister and
preacher with Kent leaving we also see
the cat he thought was Ben's that cat
has been sitting around the house during
the entirety of the movie and it is
revealed the cat's name is tater tot one
of Alyssa's favorite foods and this is
another ghost wink reminding him that
she'll always be there with him I want
to extend a huge thanks to Jessica
Clemens for writing this breakdown she
is the ultimate hitchhiking ghost of new
rock stars and that's why you'll see her
little ghost Wings in all of our videos
still please subscribe to all three
channels in the new rockstars Network
follow me Eddie avos follow Jessica Lulu
underscore Clemons follow new rock stars
and thanks for watching see you next
time everybody bye
[Music]